beam us up this ceremony this morning is
really wonderful
it's a special day as the og captain
kirk gets immortalized with a handprint
ceremony your hands the cement still on
there
uh the cement yeah no but my hands are
all swollen the 91 year old is all
smiles and has nothing but love for his
fans how do you define that relationship
you have with the fans
what's the importance of them to your
career have you ever dealt with a fickle
lover
[Music]
you don't know well you said the wrong
thing and they walk out fans can be
fickle so you need to be productive and
offer decent entertainment so they come
to see what it is you're doing and
approve of it so it's a
it's a very tentative emotional
experience with the fans and it's two
kirks for the price of one yes paul
wesley who plays a young james t kirk on
star trek strange new worlds is offering
his support
it was lovely seeing paul up there with
you he's taking up the mantle of uh of
captain kirk what were your
conversations with him like about the
role what were the things he asked you
we have nothing to talk about
he's
young
thin and rich he's devoted his day to
coming down here and his presence and
that's like
unbelievable i'm moved by that
one of my favorite things i've seen in
the last few years was your reaction to
actually going up into space
i mean after that
what's like what's next on the bucket
list
an interview on canadian tv
see what's happening we did it
stratosphere
us